le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
on l'appelle l'or rouge de la plaine des
palmistes
le goyavier fait partie du paysage et du
patrimoine de la commune sa culture se
développe mais la demande est toujours
plus forte
alors comment accompagner et structurer
cette filière en devenir
c'est ce que tente de réaliser le
département et les collectivités
concernées depuis quelques années sur le
terrain sylvie marcel et georges marie
nous font un état des lieux de
l'activité
[Musique]
c'est au pied de la cascade biberon à la
plaine des palmistes que les derniers
goyavier de la saison sont cueillies
marcel et producteur de goyavier depuis
près de 15 ans à l'époque il faisait
office de pionnier dans ce domaine est
déjà en route mais en plein champ comme
ça que pour les trois formateurs avec
sylvie une voisine est venue l'aider ce
matin elle s'est lancée dans l'activité
en 2007 avec l'impression de redécouvrir
cette saveur de son enfance c'est la
plaine chocolat le goyavier mais je
connaissais le goyavier sur le pied au
mans je vois là mais pas le côté le côté
utile le style du bois à vos côtés
qu y aviez fruits je n'avais pas mesuré
l'importance corde car ces dernières
années la demande en goyavier n'a cessé
d'augmenter
yaourt glaces boissons les industriels
sont devenu friand du petit fruit rouge
[Musique]
problème la production sur la plaine des
palmistes ne suffit pas à répondre à
cette demande
on ne dénombre aujourd'hui qu'une
vingtaine d'exploitants pour promouvoir
leurs activités
les producteurs ont créé l'association
note goyavier dont sylvie et l'ancienne
présidente et marcel le président actuel
[Musique]
un encadrement nécessaire car au niveau
législatif aujourd'hui la filière est
encore dans le flou tout d'abord il
n'existe pas de statut officiel de
producteurs de goyaviers et pour cause
le goyavier est une espèce exotique
envahissante aux portes du parc national
elle pourrait mettre en péril la
végétation endémiques et indigènes en
2012 une loi interdit même sa plantation
mais pour les producteurs exploiter le
goyavier c'est lutter contre sa
propagation chez georges mariée à un
autre producteur de la plaine les arbres
ont été espacées
une technique qui permet un ramassage
plus simple et plus sûr
planté comme cela on participe quand
même à l'écologie a pas de dispersion
apprennent rien donc le goyavier c'est
en fin de compte c'est comme ça c'est
comme ça il faut faire des choix en
faisant comme ça on peut le contrôler
puisque on ramasse tous les fruits qui
assurent le pied il n'y a pas de
diminution est très peu de piétine âge
aussi au niveau des des forêts puisque
les gens viennent dans les vergers pour
venir cueillir maintenant c'est plus
facile depuis 2010 des négociations et
des études sont en cours entre les
producteurs le département la commune et
les différents partenaires la commune de
l'appel ne pas lui c'est indissociable
du goyavier la reconnaissance de ce
savoir faire de cette culture et ceux
goyavier fruits rempli de vitamine c qui
n'est plus seulement considérée comme
une peste végétale mais comme un atout
supplémentaire est l'objet de la
convention que nous mettons en oeuvre
avec le maire de la plaine des palmistes
et tous ses habitants pour faire
rayonner le produit goyave y est le
fruit des y aviez mais aussi le
territoire de la plaine des palmistes et
de l'acier
et bien chose et cette année mais d'où
vient la bien chaussé enjeux écologiques
et économiques
le petit fruit est aussi très rentable
je les sirops confitures coulis
il se décline à l'infini
très vaste à explorer la pâtisserie la
restauration voilà sylvie et ses
confrères attendent avec impatience la
signature de la convention qui encadrera
enfin leur profession parallèlement une
poignée d'entre eux tentent de créer un
j ai eu un groupement d'intérêt
économique et environnemental le début
d'un vrai statut pour la filière
goyavier et ses producteurs
on a besoin d'être reconnus aussi quoi
je ne peux pas rester marginal comme ça
alors que la besogne on a besoin de nos
goyaviers le partenariat entre la
commune la panacée le conseil général
c'est vrai que c'est un monsieur c'est
quand même un grand pas vraiment une
grande avancée
[Musique]
à la plaine des palmistes la production
de goyavier est estimé à 300 tonnes par
an elle est réalisée par une vingtaine
de producteurs qui exploite entre 30 à
50 hectares du territoire communal pour
augmenter la production et structurer la
filière des études et des réflexions ont
été engagés par différents acteurs
depuis 2012 en 2016 un projet de
convention n'a été présentée il
permettra notamment aux producteurs
d'accéder aux aides départementales
pour plus de renseignements rendez vous
sur le site du département au
www.cglpl.fr
[Musique]